We're crushing our videos
into bite-size pieces
for your inspiration and entertainment.
I'm Grant Thompson,
and this is
King of Random Rewind.
10. MARIO TURTLE SHELLS
9. BASIC BREAD
8. "COKE-A-NUT" DRINK
7. ZIPLOC BAG HACK
6. SALT WATER TO BLEACH
5. GUM FIRESTARTER
4. GAS - FIRECRACKERS
3. DIY DEHYDRATOR
2. NET GUN ATTACHMENT
1. DIY PUZZLE BOX
Hey guys, Grant here.
I hope you enjoyed this compilation.
If you want to see the full
tutorials for these videos,
we got links down
in the description.
If you like to see another compilation,
click the box up there.
And if you're not already a subscriber,
go ahead and click the bomb,
we'll see you in the next video.
Talk to you then.